[Musique]
mini bibis
aléatoire va cercle
on râle et l'eau verte ça fait presque
un an pour certaines qui est que vous
pensent à ce jour là et là ça fait
quelques mois on est tous là c'est ce
soir que ça se passe vraiment on est
tous ensemble donc on va tous arrivés là
haut on casse de tous d'accord
[Musique]
à
on
m
bon
[Musique]
madame messieurs vos soins qu'un camion
a foncé dans la foule annezin kings
carrière de miss une fin
sur la promenade des anglais bilan
effroyable au vainqueur
[Musique]
on a des anglais ces deux symboles de
nice et c'est là où tu sors de samedi
soir c'est là où tu
tu donne rendez-vous à ta première
amoureuse c'est là où tu vas
à la plage pour faire le beau c'est là
où mon fils il a appris à faire du vélo
et là où tu fais du roller et que tu te
casses la gueule c'est là où tu rigoles
c'est là où on voit là où tu es jeune et
tu bois ton premier verre
[Musique]
un symbole c'est
apprendre et apprendre
[Musique]
ça fait quoi ça fait une heure quand
marche pratiquement une heure comment tu
la sens quand un truc motivés motivés
hyper motivés et
bien sûr je crois revers ça c'est sûr
[Musique]
d'ailleurs on les entend il parle tout
ça entre donc ça c'est le top c'est un
bon signe
[Musique]
borgna un peu plus de 2000 mètres et
encore une fois bravo mais bon
c'est vrai on n'a fait que six hommes de
dénivelé positif c'est rien du tout
faire parce que là bas il y aura mille
deux cents mètres de dénivelé positif
dans la nuit à traverser un glacier plus
de 18 heures de marche qu'est ce qu'on a
fait on a fait deux heures et demie de
marche aller à les trois heures c'est de
la rigolade et
je crois en vous mais
mais pas trop j'aime de s'entraîner
s'entraîner s'entraîner il faut
s'entraîner et on n'est pas prêt on
n'est pas prêt
droit à l'entraînement
enfin c'est à tous les jours petit
détail m'entraîner tous les jours
tu démerde le matin tôt le soir tard
marché ou nager ou nager
là je vais aller courir n'est pas tous
les jours voulant qu'un jour ma cocotte
et la raison elle en aime pas beau
journal 14 juillet ils ont voulu écrire
l'histoire et nous on va continuer on va
pas laisser l'histoire s'arrêter sur soi
sur son jeu se joue sur ce jour là on va
essayer d'écrire une petite page très
modestement dans ce groupe et on va on
va dépasser ce qui s'est passé journée
se rapprocher à ce projet finalement
inconsciemment c'est peut-être aussi tu
vois
revenir là-dessus dire
voilà moi j'étais pas là le jour même
j'ai fait pas fait partie des équipes
d'urgence du samu
mais voilà quelque part c'est pour
montrer que l'on n'est que fin mois pour
moi je suis solidaire on est tous
solidaires on y pense tout le temps moi
chaque entraînement je pense à ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis en train de récupérer et de
choisir légal et
illégal et pour le projet malaya
la cei a pas grandement 17h15 du matin
donc
à la recherche des galets
[Musique]
pas mal
une forme de coeur
je prends des galets qui sont un peu
plus gros que d'autres ce qui représente
les personnes qui sont plus âgés ou des
gars les plus petits les personnes
incertain à un âge plus jeune donc je
suis là il n'est pas mal avec cette
couleur qui est un peu claires qui est
pas mal je récupère
segal et de la province et c'est pas
rien ça représente losange
[Musique]
la promenade gellé pratiquement jamais
lâché j'ai reproduit ici au bout de 15
jours
[Musique]
c'est tellement beau
c'est difficile de penser cette baisse
s'applique déjà baie des anges avant que
avant que le drame ma belle fille
habitait à côté avec sa maman
on essaie de se relever mais
de voir une photo de voir des paysages
comme ça la promenade qui a repris son
cours
son cours normal de sa vie
et vous dites que l'année dernière à la
même époque elle était là avec sa maman
et que la vie est éphémère
et qu'elle peut s'arrêter du jour au
lendemain
[Musique]
c'est à nice on a le sang chaud il y à
fond nous tous proches comme il
méditerranéen
[Musique]
c en est fier hélas d'être touchés comme
ça en plein coeur fait sans pouvoir rien
faire sans nombre d'élus en sang c'est
tout ce toit pince les lèvres à ce
moment là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi ça fait partie aussi de nice ici
placez votre petit point tu vois
parce que mon big n ici c'est génial
avec un pain bagnat et
bouteilles d'eau ont passé la journée
ici
pour mon entraînement je vais jusqu'ici
les jeunes âges jusqu'à nice
[Musique]
je n'ai pas avec moi
et à coup les gens qui ont souffert des
longues heures de longs jours de longs
mois et encore pendant des années
là une motivation importante pour le
peuple niçois le peuple français puis
tous les tous les gens qui gardent
l'espoir et de l'enthousiasmé pour que
cette vie est resté joly est magnifique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
[Applaudissements]
ça va et vous vous allez bien ça va
je vous amener une surprise ou la wii
tout est la plus dure des chantiers
d'après vous qu'est ce que je vous ai
emmenés
oui
c'est bien avancé
et vous lui avez dit quel coup là on
avait choisi pour les plaintes du coup
de blanc rouge et pourquoi
le cas du tout et pourquoi enfin 80
cigale et n'attend pas pour l'attentât
de who we et pourquoi 86 jason maîtresse
ya une fête à un camion avec quelqu'un
de bien et est
une ville très jeune et il a écrasé en
tout et il écrase aider des personnes
est en tout cas il y à
86 morts est donc
légale et c'est pour eux sont remplis
d'aidé victimes et killian pourquoi
pourquoi c'est important voilà pourquoi
c'est important pour les victimes qu'on
fasse légale était au foyer soit pas
s'engueuler orange et d'air pur pour
mieux franchir cette étape
[Musique]
et moi je suis qui a ignoré oui et je
suis qui pourquoi je pars avec vous les
gars line
tnt une par an dans une jeune fille
mais qu'est ce qu'elle avait ma fille al
ala et est mort ce à cause du gros
camion
très bon
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça me manque
beaucoup d'émotion
c'est vraiment un moment on pense à la
victime
et quelque part quand je pars le nom en
noir dessus après c'est un peu la chair
de poule voilà c'est j'ai vraiment
l'impression voilà de rendre hommage
individuellement à chaque victime ne
sont plus un tout c'est plus les 86
victimes c'est individuellement chaque
victime et chaque victime est aussi
importante celle ci me chaque galets du
coup est aussi importants les uns que
les autres et là c'est une petite fille
décédée avec sa manier son cousin qu
est la vie mais anna deux ans
une des plus chères
[Musique]
on
et
[Musique]
oh
on est parti de paris peu de temps après
à des attentats de paris où là vraiment
on avait ressenti déjà
vraiment une grosse boule au ventre si
on n'avait pas été impacté directement
c'est notre ville qui avait été vraiment
agressé et on est arrivé au mois de juin
à nice et le fait que
le fait qu'un mois après on va vivre un
petit peu la même chose on avait
l'impression qu'ici ils pouvaient jamais
fait qu'il aurait jamais pu nous arriver
quelque chose on sentait vraiment en
sécurité mais à tort parce que mon en
sécurité nulle part et
soit que ça a été ça nous a un peu cassé
je pense dans
vois pas d'autres
arrivé c'est en tout cas
donc c'était une très belle journée
ensoleillée n'y faisait chaud c'était
c'était l'été donc beaucoup de touristes
animé par la ville était animée
dit que le feu d'artifice c'est terminé
on est parti directement et par chance
nous habitions dispo est donc on
marchait dans le bon sens et du coup
j'ai vu le camion arrivait et en fait
j'ai vu quelqu'un se faire percuter à
une centaine de mètres de nous et enfin
c'est là qu'on est là qu'on a compris
qu'il fallait vraiment qu'on se jette
rapidement
on a entendu un coup de feu
premier réflexe humain je le pense et
puis après du fait aussi une profession
on y aller quand même même si on n'avait
pas le même avec la peur on oublie un
peu con appelant voit la fin il vient
une dame qui était en train de réanimer
un petit enfant
pas possible ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour nous cette expérience est quelque
chose de très important nos gars
laissant la fois une mémoire et
l'expérience les mandats ou 86 10 par an
la mémoire de cette tragédie
la mémoire de notre ville mais également
la mémoire de notre pauvre où nous
galets sont une espérance un espoir
c'est notre cri silencieux notre façon
de nous révolter et d'envoyer notre
message au plus haut les faire briller
les laisser la haute dans le ciel
non je vous remercie vraiment surpris
pro forma
[Applaudissements]
c'est difficile à supporter dans le sang
soit on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des familles
complètes quasiment qui sont inscrits
sur ces galets
ça on fait ça pour rendre un hommage
mais prend la personne ou noir 1 et ce
con c'est important de garder une
réserve par rapport aux familles on
connaît pas leur souffrance et
en même temps il ya des liens qui se
créent forcément moyens emilie la maman
de romain madame petitjean qui m'a
demandé de je voulais bien porter son
fils tu vois il ya des liens qui se
créent un petit peu malgré tout parce
qu'il ya des gens qui ont perdu leur
sens enfin et qui reste proche quand
même du projet et voilà après on essaye
de rester neutre par rapport à tout ça
mais mais forcément des personnes comme
emilie comme annecy c'est compliqué de
ne pas créer des liens d'amitié profonds
c'est une histoire
c'est l'histoire plus émouvantes je
crois que j'ai jamais vécue parce qu
elle est suite à un drame et en tant
elle est un symbole d'espoir elle est
[Musique]
là on peut plus jamais ça et nous en
serons au plus près
c'est tout ça à la fois c'est très
perturbant
si vous êtes personnellement touché par
le pont petit personnes
le petit gars au fait partie de ces 86
temple
forcément ça me parle encore plus
les cotisants donc
je te le dis dans ce cas là haut et si
j'y arrive pas il ya quelqu'un qui
passait de séjour en tout cas c'est un
honneur pour moi aussi c'est là pour moi
merci beaucoup
ce matin vous avez été au top
d'accord vous êtes super bien comportés
voilà et vous avez moi je suis très fier
de vous pouvez être fiers de vous au
site est bien d'accord vous avez été
super on est super comportez vous avez
vous
fait des beaux galles et je pense que
tout le monde dans les très
reconnaissant d'accord et voilà ça vaut
une belle aventure qui se termine là on
va aller dire au revoir à nos marcheurs
on va leur dire prenez soin de nos
galets et monter les tout en un d'accord
encouragez vous dire merci et c'est
comme si vous mangez avec moi et prenez
soin de nos gagnants
les abîmes rappaz on en prendra soin les
verts en salade
[Musique]
oh
on va venir
j'ai eu un moment de ne pas bien bon ok
duré que quelques heures mais ce matin
je suis mieux c'était juste des maux de
tête
nausées
difficultés pour marcher bon j'étais pas
top mais après 16 ou pas trop ça va mais
par contre dès que ça monte un peu
pareil bernard était pas très bien ce
matin mon
mieux maintenant on arrête à nouveau
pour lui
[Musique]
c'est trop beau si
tu sais bernard où il est le stock comme
on dit quand vous voyez d'ici
c'est super bon c'est très dépaysant
ladd et les montagnes enfin la ville en
pleine montagne c'est sa magnifique voix
sont pas bonnes tout petit peu frustré
de pas encore voir vraiment les
montagnes on a bien peu caché dans
l'avion quand il s'en est vraiment dans
une vallée au milieu de montagne
super besse chaîne de montagnes dont les
a plus revus depuis donc on est
un peu sur mars quand même
là on est un des traits 3005
c'est encore rien comparé à ce qui nous
attend
là ça a l'air très très enneigée par
contre 1
et le fait qu'ils peuvent depuis 2 jours
2 va pas mais si ça c'est
en verra bien ça fait fondre
[Musique]
à
ce matin
doit bénir les galets il ya une
cérémonie prédire qu'un moine
le
c'est toujours mon master ensemble
galets dans la caisse qu'est-ce qui a
été conçu spécialement pour ça pour nous
je pense que c'est un moment important
et pour les personnes de monsieur qui
nous ont confié leurs enfants leurs
parents aussi
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
je
emma
[Musique]
squash
je
[Musique]
saulnier bayrou
c'est très énervant parce qu'en fait
une surprise pour moi dans sa part qu on
avait plaisir à gaza
victime pendant un temple ici donc en
fait on a l'impression que ne pas
stocker les religions
[Musique]
regarde où en est et on peut monter à
6000 à ce que tu veux 6003 jean saisrien
le mal des montagnes tout ce que tu veux
on va souffrir non les gens qui
souffrent
ils sont
sera ni s'ils sont dans le monde entier
ils ont perdu leurs enfants ils ont
perdu leurs femmes leurs maris ce qu'ils
ont de plus cher c'est là que tu
souffres mois si demain je souffre si
demain je perds mes enfants mais je
n'existe plus quoi j'ai tout perdu et si
juste à emilie je peux lui amener mieux
ans de sourire mais je suis le plus
heureux donc je vais monter là haut
avec le mal des montagnes ou pas j
manque
[Musique]
ce ton
elle s'apparente là encore regarder non
le chef faut-il pas the size forme y
sommes
quand tu fais ça c'est
autre chose à la montée on est certes
loin que la décence
valentré
c'est l'honneur de seulement les
quelques pages est particulièrement mal
alors que vous aimiez vous à leur tour
qui arrivait a bien serré nos visiteurs
et comment tu seras là autant
qu'ils sont là
c2c deux crochets ça permet de les
verrouiller d'accord quand tu fais ça et
ça comme ça
là tu lâches j'adore le groupe parce que
je sors très souvent avec des copains y
ait des gens qui sont aguerris à la
montagne il reste un groupe assez
hétéroclite et c'est vrai que il ya des
personnes que jérémy des crampons car
j'avais couché dans un duvet sous une
tente et je trouve ça fantastique
la
salle à brackley
[Musique]
amadouer
tout parce que tu es bien mais bon
rien c'est comme la table muriel te
constate que c'est hyper de 30 ans
j'arrive à émettre à une paire de
chaussures elles ont fait raison c'est
le mont blanc
[Musique]
bon vous avez tous cinq minutes pour la
remise des galets didier muriel on va
remettre les galets
estime
nico sur pierre à l'ego aller la remise
des galères
noémie
jusqu'au bout un duel
/
oh je compte sur toi délicatement budget
ça monte c'est sûr merci g7 galles et
les autres non je n'ai jamais rien de
plus mais ta vie je suis un peu je suis
un peu je suis un peu plus large je
mange plus que les autres même je n'ai
rien de plus non mais c'est surtout que
je me suis engagé auprès de certains et
puis voilà mais t'inquiète set ça passe
et le romain il sera à bien la bride à
mansac et montre à la hausse
sur toi
il ya ce galet en particulier que je
souhaite amener en eau parce que le soir
du 14 juillet c'est l'enfant qu'on a
essayé de
sauvée avec nicolas
il est important pour nous
de le prendre avec nous et de l'emmener
en hausse du stock combien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
paul baysse
m
non
[Musique]
oh
on
un million de chats - je crois qu'ils
sont venus tout près des tentes
réveil animal
ses débuts kg parce que c'est lui tout
ce type et qui était embarqué du camp
un beau spectacle à boire pour les
disciplines olympiques lors de lui parce
que
il en train de grimper tout doucement
regarde leur temps
c'est un petit cadeau du réveil du matin
avec le soleil qui se lève c'était
absolument magique magic
or
[Musique]
oh
bon
allez
allez allez parler
là
[Applaudissements]
même si on part à 22h moins chier c'est
vrai que la misère tu auras tu vas me
maudire après c'est normal on se met la
pression on est là le store qu'il est là
et même moi mais moi j'ai peur c'est
normal j'imagine quatre niveaux
différents en fait du coup c'est ça qui
nous pose question bien si tu vois c'est
comme aujourd'hui on est trop dispersée
dans la montagne il ya des gens qui
vraiment avoir très froid et ça ça casse
les jambes pour montrer un guide à
d'accord non le rythme serait une réelle
d'accord bien célibat danger pour muriel
on fera tout pour muriel l'erreur tu
sais quelle est leur bon rythme c'est
vrai mais après dans la nuit c'est
différent c'est vrai mais moi je moi
j'ai perdu personne peut aussi mettre
les personnes après bien sûr on prendra
pas de risques et ainsi nourrir le
moindre problème bien sûr on dira mme
hurel de redescendre mais là il faut
pousser muriel jusqu'au bout et
maintenant c'est elle qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors
ok
je vais journée regorge on herbauges que
ce soir on devrait partir en juste après
le dîner lien on sent en forme et dans
la lf dalhem la sanction va être lu
quand même
moi j'ai peur qu'on soit épuisé fin
je me sens bien mais tant pouvoir donc
nos cauchemars sens bien je pense en
bien et puis en fait quand on fait trois
pas pour aller chercher un toit de toile
aux toilettes pour les chercher quelque
chose on est épuisé
donc 15 heures de marche
comme ça ça va être long
deux types mines j'ai pas dormi la nuit
tu peux fermer l'oeil
voilà ça va
c'est ce soir passe vite
on est dans la tempe
peut-être le plus difficile
[Musique]
je
je me sens comment dire
j'ai un but donc c'est arrivé un à
déposer les galets au nom des victimes
donc moi j'ai plusieurs galles est un
ges de de myriam de sa maman léa de
de camille mûrissent la fille d'anne
mûrissent et le fait de rendre un
hommage plus près du ciel
en déposant des galets c'est à la fois
penser effectivement à toutes les
victimes et penser aux
comment dire la meilleure façon de leur
rendre hommage j'ai l'impression que en
prolongent leur vie
et d'un fourneau atomique c'est vrai
mais ces séries soleil chine a monté les
hélicos reste au cari yens mardi
mais la plage quand alain chaussettes
shirt
ça fait du bien au groupe
il est passionant
mangeant des mots actuellement à 4900
mètres des barlagne à rouvrir les vannes
prouesse on a des experts certains
debout et voilà la deuxième variété de
momo les steam immense et en fait c'est
lé moment vapeur je pense que le nom de
toute l'équipe je peux dire que c'est le
meilleur restaurant d'altitude que nous
connaissons
ce soir là on met tout ça a presque 5000
ya là beaucoup pour classer la première
fois
alors
je sais pas si je parle au nom de
l'équipe mais en tout cas en tout cas
voilà si on est là c'est grâce à toi
donc donc voila moi je tiens vraiment à
remercier je sais pas si j'arriverai en
rouge je vais tout faire pour que l'on y
arrive tous merci à vous tous parce que
parce que moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très bien
trucy pierre ça se voit et ça s'entend
allez allez
il est là le chemin aux kings
l'homme atteint les 5400 clos que le
mont blanc
au nom tube à bulles
c'est un endroit qui est quand même
assez dangereux
il ya beaucoup des verts il ya des
radins
moi je pensais c'est ça qu'il faut
vraiment faire attention en permanence
je suis dans le dur cela vient de
commencer leur bientôt attaquer glaciers
c'est surtout hâte que le jour se lève
on va dire qu'on est presque
ça va être le mur de glace a pas
traversé
donc il ya le mur
et c'est un mur quand on dit que c'est à
murcie un mur
la violence
je
sa voix
les gaulois pas de pause
allez go
avec moi
[Musique]
nous
tu mets pas en danger si tu peux plus ça
n'en vaut pas la peine c'est vrai noël
c'est déjà un miracle est arrivé
jusqu'ici tu dois être à 5700 5800
le sourire et le lien mick mars et les
tropéziens
qu'elle s'arrête là elle et elle a fait
un bon chemin long chemin déjà je prends
ça très mûrs et
enfin bon un frein à la hausse et oui
les
particules
j'ai essayé de monter mais galley le
plus loin possible
après la troisième ou quatrième fois où
on demande
on nous propose de prendre un peu du
poids j'ai fini par accepter
j'ai gardé jusqu'au bout trois des
galères dois je voulais je voulais
surtout pas donné
[Musique]
quand
il pour
[Musique]
tu sais
bordel là c'est une gueule
c'est un peu comme si tu étais un peu en
dehors de ton corps
tu te dis t'as pas le droit quoi tu veux
pas tu peux pas avoir mal aux jambes tu
peux pas
et puis tous ces galella tous ces
prénoms qu'on a dans le sac déprimant de
gamin de 4 ans 7 à 8 sont des familles
entières et c'est ça qui te porte
finalement
[Musique]
remettre les allées
l'âge de m
[Musique]
mais toi tu t'es bon
comme moi j'aimais
oshima
si l'otan sous les habits la maison
estime
je suis moi même
c'était sûr
[Musique]
c'est un moment un moment de soulagement
mais un moment
de plein d'émotions de ces moments forts
et après tu te poses un petit peu mais
là vient le temps tu sortais galets et
tu repenses en fait
l essentiel de pourquoi tu es là
c'est magique c'est magique
[Musique]
travaux restent à l'égaler on va rendre
hommage à toutes les victimes et
toutes les familles qui sont qui sont
endeuillées et toutes les personnes qui
ont porté secours ce soir là donc on va
se poser tout à l'heure et
est respecté une minute de silence pour
eux
durant la session je pense effectivement
au nom de l'enfant qui était inscrit sur
le galet c'est ça qui m'a quand même
re motiver quand j'étais un petit peu en
difficulté est arrivé là où j'étais
vraiment contente de le sortir et de le
poser sur le drapeau et voilà de de
l'avoir emmené jusqu'en haut
[Musique]